Hey! Where are we going?!
Wait up here. I'll be right back.
Why is she so bossy?
Don't peek, you pervert!
Why are guys always so stupid and horny?!
Okay, Asuka... it's game time.
Why can't we sink it?!
I guess only an Eva can beat those things.
Okay, let's get out there.
You, too! You're coming with me!
Hey, why did we get changed
into plug suits?!
Are you an idiot?
Why do you think? We're going to
take that thing out with my Unit 02!
Is that okay? Shouldn't we get
Ms. Misato's permission?
I'll get her permission after my victory.
Okay, I'm going to show you
how a real pilot does it.
But don't cause any trouble, got it?
That's strange... It's almost
like it's looking for something.
Getting attacked by an Angel out here
wasn't part of the deal.
That is why Unit 02 is there.
I even sent a backup pilot.
If it comes down to it,
escape on your own.
Understood.
[speaking German]
There's a bug. What's wrong?
Cognitive noise!
I told you not to cause trouble, didn't I?
What did I do?
You're thinking in Japanese, aren't you?
Think in German, damn it!
Oh, okay...
Um, Baumkuchen--
Idiot! All right, fine!
Change cognitive linguistics!
Set basic to Japanese!
Evangelion Unit 02! Activate!
Message from the Othello:
Eva-02 is activating!
It's what?!